a slightly karma day for stock markets
yesterday some exchanges saw their
steepest one-day drop since 2015 today a
more mixed picture in London the stock
exchange opened slightly up but in New
York closing sharply down that's partly
because Chinese factories are slowly
reopening signaling a replenishment of
global supply chains and because fears
of a truly global pandemic haven't been
realized although it's far from over now
is the time to prepare so we're in a
phase of preparedness for a potential
pandemic so preparation is now the name
of the game in the United States the
White House asked Congress for 2.3
billion euros to prepare medical workers
and to find a vaccine Japan's
preparation staggering the daily commute
companies and organizations please
encourage your employees with cold-like
symptoms to take leave and we ask that
you promote telecommuting or even
working staggered hours but countries
with major outbreaks such as here in
South Korea or in Iran and in Italy
business as usual it's hard to maintain
of course an economic impact due to the
suspension of activity including for the
region's directly affected but we're
ready to deal with this emergency you'll
see that will limit the negative impact
including the economic impact analysts
are now not predicting a global downturn
because governments are willing to step
in with liquidity and lower interest
rates to stimulate the economy let's get
some more insight on the impact of kovat
19 where's Ricardo cuarto he is the
China representative of Germany's
association of supply chain management
procurement and logistics welcome to the
program Ricardo where do you see the
biggest disruption at the moment well
thank you for having me first for what
we can observe the point is that more
and more companies whether which have
production for
and supplying facilities over in China
they see that right now capacity figures
are reopening labor is coming slowly
back to work which means that production
capacity cannot reach that level that it
used to have before and taking this into
consideration with the extend its
Chinese New Year break many companies
are prepared for this issue but now we
have to really focus on how the next two
weeks will go on so that production
lines and supply chains can reopen and
start working again as they used to
before now we hear of some companies
trying to shift their production out of
China what do you make of that
yeah that's true that's also something
that we heard through our BME member
Network in China you have to see that
the German companies or European
companies are working very close
together with their Chinese supplier
base and they are looking to get let's
say a mutual solution for this because
it's not in the interest of the Chinese
supplier to destroy this relation
because of the coronavirus so more and
more and those German companies which
cannot fulfill their demand in China are
looking for alternative suppliers also
from their supplier base back in Europe
that's true and how are your member
countries in particular trying to arm
themselves against the impact of this
epidemic well this is the you have to
see this on the one on one perspective
you cannot talk generally over the whole
industry since we are representing a lot
of industries so basically more and more
companies are focusing on their stocks
on their stock issues if this stock
management will allow them to go on with
their production capacities then it's
good if this stock for producing the
materials like raw materials components
and so on will continue to shrink then
this will have for sure and impacts on
all the further activities that
company will take I mean they are
running into major difficulty then yeah
of course this is something now where
our companies see that risk management
is getting more and more important
analysis of these entire supply chain
and analysis of the entire supply issue
and supplier portfolio to see where can
we shift some issues are alternatives
routes of transport and issue so all
these aspects putting all together under
concrete evaluation and analysis also
for the future to be even better
prepared if such kind of situation
should ever cure again and Ricardo
briefly what do you expect from
authorities in Germany and on the
Chinese side and that's a good question
thank you I think especially from the
Chinese authorities I think transparency
keeping up transparency is crucial so
that we all can get an idea about the
about a dimension that this virus is
bringing to the global impact and
furthermore from the German authorities
also talking about the German federal
government so far we believe that the
risk management is quite good but
however if this crisis will continue on
having an impact federal government
should also have a look on not only on
the health issue but also write what
they could do to stimulate or to protect
the German environment in terms of
economy regard a quarter of Germany's
association of supply chain management
procurement and logistics thank you for
talking to DW now Viet Nam's textile
sector could suffer as a result of the
new coronavirus producers are
forecasting a severe shortage of
materials during the second quarter of
the year companies say they have
sufficient materials until the end of
the first quarter but production beyond
that could be hampered by difficulties
importing from key suppliers in China
Japan and South Korea China provides
more than half the materials for Viet
Nam's garment industry textiles
represent Viet Nam's third biggest
export earner after smartphones
in advance US President Donald Trump is
wrapping up his two